[Music]
[Applause]
today it's my great pleasure to
introduce to you a man who's been so far
ahead of the pack that if I said he was
cutting edge I'd actually be insulting
him for being slow this is the man who
taught us that ulcers could be treated
through antibiotics that kidney stones
were actually a Calcium deficiency that
rheumatoid arthritis was an immune
problem that again could be treated with
antibiotics all these are mainstream
strategies today but 10 or 20 years ago
when doc started it was very of onard in
fact probably heresy I want to get into
today Doc's newest statement which is
exercise without supplementation is
suicide and Doc this is a very
intriguing concept but you know down
through the years you've had so many
things be proven right time and time
again I guess my first question to you
is are you the Sherlock Holmes of a
healthcare or uh I like to think so I I
think that's probably a pretty kind
description of what I do and of course
the thing that made Sherlock Holmes
famous was the fact that he would say
just the opposite of what Scotland Yard
was saying and he was always right
I'd say you hit the nail right on the
head I like to be a Sherlock Holmes what
got you onto this line of thinking
especially with the athlete right now
everybody's telling folks to exercise so
are they just putting their head in the
Noose they're actually putting their
head in the Noose they're actually
cutting their life by 30 40 50 years if
they exercise and don't supplement where
I ran into this was about 50 years ago
people began to study what sweat was and
they are these little bitty articles in
Biochemistry journals the makeup of
sweat it was very interesting most
people thought sweat was primarily just
salt and water but sweat contains
everything that's in your blood and as
you sweat the primary purpose of course
is to cool your body but you're also
losing nutrients you're losing amino
acids you're losing vitamins you're
losing major minerals you're losing
electrolytes you're losing trace
minerals Rare Earth and it's a kind of a
trickle charge it's kind of like the
toilet that just sort of runs a little
bit drip drip drip you get a water bill
for 500 bucks at the end of the month
doesn't seem like much but does in fact
cost you in health and longevity and so
about 25 years ago because I was an
athlete in high school and college I
played football and wrestled of course
you sweat a lot in both those Sports and
I only weighed 123 lbs and played middle
linebacker and played offensive Center
that's back in the old days when players
played both offense and defense and only
had 123 pounds I was very aggressive but
never got an injury and all these big
guys 200 240 PBS were always getting
injuries and their ankles and so forth
and the reason I didn't was because
living on the farm I was able to have
access to trace minerals that we gave to
Cals and so putting together practical
experience and taking advantage of some
what was 50 years ago esoteric research
you know what's in sweat kind of thing
put it together and came up about 25
years ago that you were in fact throwing
your life away if you were exercising
and not replacing the minerals you're
sweating out wow you know it kind of
reminds me back I don't even know when
this was but all a sudden jogging came
up and was it Bill kick Jim fix fix okay
close Jim fix has fell with two x's FXX
and of course he died at 52 and he wrote
all the books run your way to health jog
your way to health and there wouldn't be
any running shoes and yeah wasn't a
number of the runners including him just
all of a sudden died they all do they
all die suddenly pretty profound
statement all these guys are supposed to
be healthy they have 4% body fat what it
is they're sweating out all of their
minerals which protect them from various
disease including ruptured aneurysms
including heart attacks in fact there
was a long-distance Runner who died died
in July of 2000 his name was Leonard
Hilton he ran the sub4 minute mile 32
times and he was a student of gy fixes
and always praised Jim fix and all his
knowledge and training techniques and
Jim fix died at 52 and Leonard Hilton
Jim fix a student died at 52 that's
pretty much what you're going to get
there has never been a professional
athlete Liv to be a 100 and if exercise
and of itself was useful for Health and
Longevity there should be a lot of
professional athletes living to be a 100
not a single one Craig wow it might have
been you that says a couch potato is
actually living longer than these guys
you're exactly right that's me I like to
teach people the basic Truth by saying
something is very provocative that way
they remember a concept but basically
what I did since there was lots of
Articles written by long-distance
Runners saying hey you guys we can get
high we can make our own opium in our
brain and you can get drugged out
running long distances here and get into
La La Land legally not worry about
getting arrested or anything just by
running you can lower your cholesterol
by running you can lower your body
weight a couple of points you can get
your body percentage of fat down there's
all kinds of Wonders to running how
healthy it is is good for the
cardiovascular system but it always kind
of fascinated me there was never
anything that said athletes live longer
so I decided to do my own survey and I
started looking at obituaries of
professional athletes and University and
college athletes compared with
obituaries of couch potatoes it's always
kind of funny that Librarians live to be
103 104 conductors live to be 89 95 and
Housewives live to be 115 and so forth
and the old Couch Potato lives to be 80
8 to 120 and professional athletes the
average lifespan is 62 to 65 the ones
who play the most the ones who are the
stars die the youngest and you look at
some of the famous ones red gra Jesse
Owens people like wil Rudolph babe zarus
you're probably too young remember her
but she was one of the first great women
athletes who could whip men in about 10
different sports and then there was
people like Will Chamberlain age 63
congestive heart failure Walter Payton
45 years of age died while he was
waiting for a liver transplant he was a
pristine athlete never did drugs never
smoked never did alcohol I know that
basketball player that was a real Lewis
27 years old here we go died of a
cardiopathy heart attack a simple
selenium deficiency he was about as fit
as a human being could get then there
was Sergey grof 28 years old a two-time
Gold Medal winner in figure skating it's
not just basketball players or track
stars you can be a figure skater and die
young you can be a boxer you can be a
baseball player I have a lot of very
famous baseball players Babe Ruth luk
Garrick Don Dale I have all their
obituaries I actually have one was a
pitcher for the San Diego Padres and he
was only 24 years old and he was felled
by a cardiopathy heart attack and they
were just shocked cuz he just come up
from the miners you're sweating and not
replacing those minerals you're sweating
out you're doomed to have a lot of
injuries and anything that might relate
to Mineral and nutrient deficiencies and
certainly you're going to shorten your
life if you're not replacing everything
you're sweating now wow that's
incredible because I remember
particularly with Reggie didn't he have
what's called that the dream team of
cardologist and he died anyways he had
the dream team of cardiologist so they
paid these 12 cardiologists a million
dollars each to save him and the
interesting thing was a year and a half
after Reggie died the captain the
chairman of the dream team of
cardiologists died at age 47 himself for
the same disease cardiopathy heart
disease and he was a Boston Marathon run
runner he' finished the Boston Marathon
three times his physician and died of
the same disease at age 47 can't these
guys figure this out well what happens
is they hire these personal trainers and
they hire trainers and they hire people
who are nutritionists and they're
worried about their fat intake and
they're worried about strength training
they believe falsely that strength
training is the answer for joint health
the more muscle you build up around the
joint the less lik you're already injur
it that's absolutely nonsense just ask
Bo Jackson you remember him he was his
great two sports player professional
player in baseball and football and he
dislocated a hip joint and fractured the
head of the femur the ball part of the B
and socer joint and they talked him into
putting an artificial joint in and of
course he ran around like Chester from
the old gunm smoke days I remember him
was that one leg and he was a huge man
his thighs were bigger around my chest
he was a big man and so they said why
don't we even you out we'll just take
the good hip and we'll put in an
artificial joint in there and then
you'll be Superman well of course after
that happened he hit a few baseballs and
that was about it his career was done
but if he hadd been supplementing
properly these guys could play into
their 40s and 50s I've seen this happen
we have a lot of professional athletes
who had to quit their sport after 8 10
12 years because of joint problems we
get them on our nutrient replacement
programs and just in six months time
they're stronger and more fit and have
more agility and flexibility than they
were when they were actually playing and
they just shake their heads and they say
why didn't our high price million dollar
a year trainers tell us this and they
say well they don't know it because
they're reading from Doctor written
nutrition books they're reading from
Doctor written Sports Medicine books
these folks just don't seem to have
gotten the message yet oh they haven't
because they make their money by doing
joint replacement surgeries they make
their money by doing arthroscopic
surgery they make their money by
removing meniscus they make their money
by repairing torn ligaments and so
that's what they're in the business of
doing they are not interested in
preventing these injuries because they
make their money by repairing them got
it wasn't it hollyfield that actually
was able to come back right yeah Evander
Holyfield was kind of an interesting guy
he quit in one of his fights I guess was
against Tyson he just quit he just
couldn't go on because of his lack of
strength his heart began to give out he
had hypertrophic cardiopathy heart
disease and through a mutual friend
actually a guy who lives across the
street from Evander holy field Andrew
Young you may remember the name he was
an ambassador to you and we were able to
save Andrew Young's knees and Andy young
said well why don't I see if I can take
the message of Vander Holyfield and we
got a Vander Holyfield taking some
selenium and sure enough we're able to
get his heart going again through the
selenium supplement
actually more complete program than that
but it included uh special interest in
the selenium part of the program and as
you see he was able to come back and
defend his title several times and of
course he's been boxing not necessarily
to level he want to be he's lost the
last couple of fights but he's
remarkable athlete and without that
supplementation he would have been
finished a long time ago looking at your
background you have kind of a unique
background to be talking about human
nutrition but I think it probably gives
you an interesting perspective I know
you started as an EG major and went to
veterinary school for first and then you
did a lot of research with the human
studies I think the advantage that gives
me Craig is that in animals we don't
have insurance we don't have Blue Cross
Blue Shield major medical
hospitalization Medicare and Medicaid we
don't have personal trainers we don't
have personal nutritionists and so what
we had to learn to do was prevent cure
diseases in animals with nutritional
formulas very economical to do it that
way on a herd basis put everything in
their feed pellets and that's why we
have Mouse pellets rat pellets hamster
pellets guinea pig pellets rabbit
pellets duck pellets Goose pellets pen
laying Mash chick pellets P pellets
horse pellets sheep pellets and so on
and dog food can dried cat food canned
and dried and every one of these rations
is a perfect mix of every known nutrient
necessary for these animals and if we
were to use a human healthc care type of
system especially the sports medicine
system in animals would be sticker shock
for you your hamburger would cost you
$275 a pound just to pay for the
healthcare and so I decided to take the
same concept that we did for animal
where we have special diets for animals
with heart disease kidney disease
intestinal disease liver disease eye
disease and so on these diets are
formulated so the animal can't pick out
what they want it has everything in
there necessary to focus nutritionally
on that particular organ organ system
and I deci said well if it works in
animals so well which it does why
wouldn't it work in people and so about
I'd say
1978 after trying from 64 to 78 which is
14 15 years i' written my scientific
articles and books and lectur to doctors
and I couldn't get doctors interested in
the concept they'd Pat me on the back
and say oh that's very interesting but
that's an animals not people so I went
back to school and became a physici and
began to use these preventative and
treatment concepts with nutrition like
we did in animals and certainly the
concept works like a charm in people
just like it does in the animals that's
maybe why the gentleman that told me
about you said talk to Doc Wallock he
may treat you like a dog but you get
better that was a little thing that my
patients came up with because I used to
hang my Veterinary degree on the wall
next to the medical degree and patients
had come in their eyes to get real big
but after a while they kind of realized
where I was coming from and they start
with a joke telling their friends hey if
you're not happy with what your doctor
is doing for you go see wallet now he'll
treat you like a dog but you get better
Dr Wall talking about athletes we've
talked about a lot of the professional
athletes how about the younger one high
school college players are they at risk
just the same way oh absolutely
according to the Center for Disease
Control out of Atlanta Craig a lot of
these young athletes under the age of 30
drop dead each year while they're
training exercising or participating in
sport I saw some figures earlier this
month which said that the death rate
from sudden heart attacks in young
athletes has actually gone up by 10% in
the last year and so there's no
nutrients of any value in Pepsi colola
Coca-Cola Dr Pepper gorade and so forth
and water just plain water and so these
young athletes wanting to get
scholarships wanting to get into the
pros and as a result they train hard
they do all the right things they do
what their trainers is telling them to
do they just don't supplement properly
and as a result a lot of these kids who
are really professional level quality
athletes even when they're in junior
high in high school these kids will get
injuries that will kill their career and
there's nothing worse than these people
training these kids getting them up to
the point where they are really
Superstars and then a knee blows out or
they tear an Achilles tendon or they get
a shoulder injury they get a back or
neck injury they get a finger injury and
they're pretty much done and their whole
life is ruined because their whole life
was focused on these Athletics and these
kids also o have a high rate of
depression and suicide because her whole
life has been built around being the
Superstar of the neighborhood and the
school in fact suicide in high school
athletes is the single biggest cause of
death in high school athletes wow that's
astonishing not to mention kids like
that or young people like that blowing
out a knee they've just thrown away a
lot of money that's correct not only the
investment they've already put in but
paying forward so to speak their future
investment and their life because they
know when they Excel and so forth and
have all these benefits of the training
and they have just natural Talent it's
really a shame and so I do make an
appeal to parents and coaches and
trainers out there who might be
listening to call your toll-free number
get the information and give these young
athletes a more complete replacement
program so that if they do get injured
you know if you run into a wall you're
going to get injured you can repair
quicker the likelihood of injury is very
very slim just simply by replacing
everything you're sweating out got it
people listening to this a lot of folks
were talking about especially will say
well how long do I need to take these
sort of things you take all these
supplements properly until you stop
using oxygen got it there's a reason for
that and that's because our food does
not contain these nutrients and no
matter how well you eat you could spend
a million dollars per meal and you're
still not going to get everything you
need by eating and so you do have to
consciously supplement whether you sweat
or not but if you sweat you're really
obligated to do it in a very very
intense way Calcium deficiency from
everything that we've talked about in
the past seems to be again used to use
the word epidemic and wasn't that what
got your attention at one point in time
with twitching eye or something if I
remember the story yeah my personal
story was I was a teenager 14 years old
and my eyelids would put so bad you can
actually hear him making a noise
clicking and asked my mom what it was
and she didn't know and she panicked cuz
she could see my eyelids jerking it
looked like I had some kind of
electrical thing on there my eyelids
were just twitch it looked awful and she
took me to an eye doctor had to drive 80
miles to St Louis to go to one that top
eye doctors and after a long day she
finally determined that my eyelashes
were long and they were hitting my
glasses and curling back and tickling my
eyeballs and she gave me a Maybelline
mascara eyelash brush and she said I
have to retrain my eyelashes oh I bet
that went over well oh yeah didn't go
over very well of course I was playing
football and wrestling and I could just
imagine myself sitting on the bench
there with 25 or 302 200 lb guys playing
with my eyelashes with a mayell eyelash
brush and so I just missed that
suggestion went to the school library
and started looking up muscle cramps and
muscle twitches in a health book written
by a couple of nurses and they said very
clearly that muscle cramps and muscle
twitches are caused by a Calcium
deficiency and so I went home and I
started using the calf pellets that we
gave the calves had plenty of calcium in
when all the other kids were eaten candy
and and so forth I was eating calf
pellets and so at a very early age I was
very aware that mineral supplements were
very very necessary like I said I would
take a fencing tool and knock a corner
off one of the trace mineral salt blocks
I would take calcium supplements because
I was small and playing football middle
linebacker I just never got injured in
four years of playing because even
though I was extremely aggressive
because I was taking all the raw
materials to rebuild my body and in
wrestling where you sweat more than
anything else I would spend most of my
day not in class I was running up and
down the stadium steps the football
stadiums just to stay fit for my
wrestling program and I know I sweat out
a couple of quarts of sweat a day and
without replacing those nutrients I know
I would have some injuries at least and
certainly may have died and you may
recall a couple years ago there were
many wrestlers who died suddenly yes
tried to blame it on some of the
supplements they were taking but
basically they were wearing rubber suits
and trying to lose five or 10 pounds to
get down into a lower weight class and
they just sweat out all their nutrients
and died suddenly from that but doc what
if someone to come to you and say I have
a son that's in football or does a lot
of Athletics or even a professional
athlete what would you tell them to
protect themselves well basically what
they have to do is take a good basic
supplement program that gives them all
90 essential nutrients plus the raw
materials to develop properly and
maintain repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue bone matrix
lay down the minerals necessary for a
healthy and happy bone also instead of
just using water or Gatorade or one of
the soft drinks as a fluid replacement
as they sweating before during and after
the events in the training session a
sports drink it has amino acids vitamins
electrolytes major minerals trace
minerals and rare Earths in it plus
three time relief
energy sources taste very good and it's
a concentrate you put an ounce of this
into a quart of water a liter of water
and sip on that you're going to replace
you're going to trickle charge
everything back into your system that
you're losing as you sweat and not only
will this athlete reduce their risk of
death and injury but also their stamina
is going to go way up they will be much
stronger in the third and fourth
quarters they'll be much stronger in the
long distance races in that last lap
they're going to be much stronger in any
event than the opponents
excellent so Dr wal we've kind of looked
at the problem out there minerals seem
to be the Kingpin of what you're talking
about and it's funny because everybody
talks vitamins it's a good observation
Craig because vitamins if you work real
hard you can actually get Vitamins out
of your food because plants can take
carbon out of the air manufacture
vitamin A and beta carotene and all the
B vitamins c e and K but plants cannot
manufacture minerals there's not a
single function in your body that can
take place without mineral co-actors you
cannot utilize oxygen you cannot utilize
energy you cannot utilize vitamins you
can't utilize proteins you can't utilize
enzymes you cannot utilize hormones
nothing in your body will work without
one or more mineral co-actors and yet
our Foods cannot manufacture minerals
like they do vitamins and so over the
years I realized that the minerals were
the limiting factor and the lack of
minerals were the limiting factor to
long life healthfulness athletic prowess
and stamina and I probably have known
that since I was 14 years old and
certainly developed and collected a lot
of information to back up that belief
over the years and basically minerals
are the limiting factor and so you have
to consciously supplement with them
properly especially if you're an athlete
in sweating the vitamins even a blind
hog will get an acaron sometimes they
supplement fortify white bread they
fortify rice they fortify chocolate bars
they fortify just about everything
what's this document 264 you faxed over
to me well US Senate document 264 was
actually published by the US Senate 193
6 and the US Senate published this back
in 1936 and it said at that time that
there was no longer sufficient amounts
of minerals in our farm and Rain soils
to give us everything we needed and as a
result the plants the food plants that
were grown there were minerally
deficient as a result the animals and
people who ate these minerally deficient
crops got mineral deficiency diseases
and according to US Senate document 264
the only way to prevent and cure these
mineral deficiency diseases was to
supplement properly and we've known this
in 1936 that's back at the time when we
began to supplement vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals in the
animal feeds and came up with mouse
pellets and rat pellets and hamster
pellets and guinea pig pellets and horse
pellets and canned dog and cat food and
so on to assure them optimal amounts of
all known nutrients they couldn't pick
out what they wanted unfortunately for
human beings we're left to TV
advertisements and newspaper
advertisements and magazine
advertisements and ignorant trainers who
tell people well just drink Gatorade and
just drink water and just drink
pepsicola cuz we get good kickbacks from
them do tell you this is incredible well
in fact I've got some young children
that now in the back of my head I've got
all these questions going through my
head on how to make sure that they
survive this ordeal of growing up and
and being athletes but unfortunately we
are right down to the wire we're going
to have to ask you to come back maybe do
this again love to do it Craig I want to
thank you for being with us this has
been Dr wallik National lecturer on the
Dead Doctors Don't Lie series
bestselling author physician
veterinarian and allaround good guy
thanks for being with us and for Craig
Walcott here at Health talk have a
healthy
[Applause]
day I'm here with one of my favorite
guys Mike Glenn Stinger from the NBA
from the Atlanta Hawks and currently
commissioner of the WBA how you doing
Mike oh I'm doing good doc I'm really
glad to be here I'm feeling good I've
already had my rebound drink today so
I'm fired up ready to go another game
ready to go another game Let's Play two
as Ernie Banks used to say the Sports
World well um one of the things that's
really been fascinating over the years
is to watch uh athletes professional
athletes and you'd like to think that
Fitness is is the answer to Health and
Longevity and yet the top athletes have
a struggle they break down they get
tendon problems cartilage problems
ligament problems they got bone problems
muscle problems and you think if Fitness
was the answer to
solving health problems and living a
long time that the professional athletes
would have a very high percentage of
them living be 100 and with the
exception and I know this as a fact Mike
with the exception of two black
gentlemen from the old negro baseball
leagues there's never been a
professional athlete ever lived behind
you're right one of those Ted double
duty Ratcliff who was a catcher and a
pitcher in the Negro leags died at a 101
I believe it was but you're absolutely
right other than him I don't nobody yeah
nobody and uh there's a universal reason
for this of course and and regardless of
the sport you play in whether it's
basketball or football or hockey or
soccer or boxing uh whether it's skating
or any other sport whether it's amateur
professional they all universally sweat
yes and when you're sweating Mike you
know you're not just sweating out water
you're sweating out a a soup to contains
All the known essential nutrients and if
you're just drinking water if you're
just drinking soft drinks if you're
you're just drinking one of those energy
drinks that has one or two nutrients and
we'll talk about them by the brand name
in a few minutes mhm uh you're going to
be sadly disappointed you may get a
little energy but over the Long Haul
you're going to break down and the odds
are you're not going to make it to 100
and so what what's your take on this
what have you seen over the years in
professional basketball doc uh not only
statistically doing research but in my
own personal life I just turned 50 uh
this past uh year and seven guys that I
played with in college uh have passed on
all of them from health related uh
occurrances nothing accidental so I see
in my own life the deaths and so many of
my former teammates in the NBA and
college they've had two hip replacements
knee Replacements they can hardly walk
they are really struggling so I've seen
it firsthand that a lot of the athletes
of course we read about the super
athletes like Kirby Pucket that recently
pass and uh the ultimate basketball hero
of all wil Chamberlain a guy who
averaged uh over 48 minutes a game for
an entire season average 50 points a
game he was just superum for a season
and we see wil pass at 63 and and other
Heroes of sports like of course Walter
Peyton one of the greatest if not 45 45
maybe the greatest football player that
ever lived and even somebody like wil M
Rudolph whose records are still right up
there at the top and uh it was years and
years ago 1960 since she won those three
gold medals but she was a tremendous
athlete she got 54 54 a natural athlete
had no type of enhancements whatsoever
and when we see great athletes like that
and even in our own communities younger
athletes Than That Dying we know that
there's something wrong that the people
that think if I'm just exercising then I
should live long that the message should
clearly be there for them there are
other things than exercising and being a
great athlete as far as longevity and
health is concerned yeah you're exactly
right uh commissioner I call you
commissioner yes sir and um you know you
look at somebody like Reggie Lewis died
at 28 cardiomyopathy heart attack during
a actually he had one heart attack
during a playoff game with a Charlotte
Hornets right and then some weeks later
he died of his second heart attack
selenium deficiency and then more
recently there was a young lady 19 years
old Rolanda Pierce she's a freshman in
Florida State University
6'5 she was going to be the Michael
Jordan of the WNBA she was going to be
it she dies for ruptured aneurism at age
19 something a turkey Wouldn't Die from
because we
eliminated ruptured aneurysms in turkeys
in
1947 we learned that there a simple
little copper deficiency and just by
taking copper you can prevent that so I
know the story but why don't you share
the story of one of our favorite modern
athletes Theo r sure I of course am uh
very knowledgeable of all the great
nutritional products that I take and how
they work and as a broadcaster for the
Atlanta Hawks I was talking to one of
the Hawks players not Theo Ratliff and I
was speaking kind of quietly this
gentleman had several challenges and I
was talking to him a little bit about
nutrition and Theo overheard me Theo
said Mike can I can I get with you I
want to talk to you about those
nutritional things and I met with Phil
Oliver a guy who had uh introduced me to
the products and I say Phil we need to
go out to denner with Theo Ratliff so we
went out with Theo Theo was a young
tremendous athlete who had made the
allstar team Philadelphia 76ers had
traded him to the Atlanta Hawks which is
a red flag right away why would you
trade a young 610 shot blocker who's a
tremendous person follows all the
trainers instructions all the coaches
instructions he's a family man he's
doing everything right why would you
trade a guy like that he was not a
druggy felon exactly not exactly right
this is the kind of guy you want to try
to get on your team not trade him away
so um we met with Theo uh Doc and we
went over all the nutritional things
that he needed and we pointed out that
he was very uh deficient of his
nutritions that he needs daily essential
nutrition and uh we told him the things
that he need we told him a comp uh we
told him he needed essential fatty acids
we told him he needed calcium he needed
plant derived minerals he needed a
combination of plants minerals and amino
acids and he needed glucose gel to
really repair and rebuild himself Theo
listened and he followed our
instructions he took all of this
nutrition morning and night and uh he
did that and he really recreated himself
Theo had been a guy doc that when he got
to the Atlanta Hawks his knees would
swell his ankles were um arthritic he
had a detached bone in his hip and Theo
was like 26 years old I mean an old
man's disease he's 26 years old yes and
just like we were speaking of earlier
here he's sweating out all these
nutrients yes and he's not taking him
back in to maintain and repair his body
yes he was not supporting that
maintenance system he was depending on
aerobics and fitness and muscle training
and strength training yes yes cuz the
trainers were telling them that doc they
were saying well maybe if you stretch a
little bit more so they had him all
icing and stretching and lifting weights
to strengthen those muscles in the areas
of the injury and none of it he was
continuously falling
apart so we said Theo if you'll take
these things and if you'll take them
every day we can repair and rebuild you
and Theo did he took them religiously
one of the few athletes that we've
introduced this to that have recognized
you can't just take it one time and say
oh I didn't feel anything so I just stop
taking it because they had been taking
inferior products so Theo took all of
the nutrition he went from a guy that
missed
79 out of 82 games the previous year he
only played in three games Doc and I was
right there in the locker room after
with after each one of those three he
was hurting he was oh my hip is hurting
I don't know if I can play anymore and
coaches would can you just uh play a few
minutes tomorrow night he's 26 years old
exactly like and then you know the
owners are thinking we're paying you a
lot of money for these little few
minutes all those uh Dynamics enter into
professional sports but he could not
play anymore Theo was was just in pain
and he was only hurting himself further
so he went from there to taking all the
nutrition to rebuilding himself Theo got
to the point where he was playing 822
games painfree he wasn't even icing his
knees now I played 10 years in the NBA
all centers ice their knees that
standard equipment you put your shoes on
you ice your knees after the game those
go together so Theo was so healthy he
had no pain in his knees no pain in his
hip he was pain free he was just jumping
out of the gym just blocking shots led
the NBA in shots blocked and uh was one
of the top vote Getters for a defensive
player of the year Theo was recreated he
was healthier than he had ever been
before well and then I know something
really really good happened to him after
those two great Seasons with the Hawks
what what happened to them well uh we
were talking Phil Oliver and I were
talking about how he had really uh come
around and been created and Phil came up
with the idea said we need to really
have a sports drink built around Theo so
that when Theo is uh out there he can
take all these nutritional um drinks and
supplements while he's playing and
that's when we came to you Doc and we
said can we devise an energy drink
that's full of this nutrition so that
while Theo is playing and other athletes
and other Everyday People while they're
living their everyday lives they can
take this energy drink and F an
immediate sustainable energy boost that
will take them throughout the game and
they'll even feel better the next day so
it sounded like a tall order but we knew
that it could be filled and and that's
exactly what happened rebound FX was uh
created uh we tossed around what would
be a good name and we thought that Theo
had rebounded his career and rebound
such a a part of basketball rebounding
uh you know uh you can't win without
rebounding so all of that made a lot of
sense and we came up with the name
rebound FX and Theo has taken it Theo
has introduced it to a lot of other
professional athletes as we have as well
and it has just developed and earned the
reputation of being the best sports
drink in the world and coming from a
sports uh background my nickname is the
stinger and all people know you have to
earn your nickname so if your name is
rebound FX you have to earn it and
rebound has certainly earned that name
rebound FX yeah I can remember there's
one professional basketball player I
can't mention his name but I can
remember one one guy uh one of the top
NBA players uh he wasn't going to play
on a Sunday and we were at one of those
basketball clinics on Saturday and they
actually had to have one of the kids who
was there who was going back to Miami
hand carry case of rebound FX to this
basketball player because he wasn't
going to play without it that's right
what a great story doc you're right
trying out for the WBA you mentioned I'm
the commissioner of the World Basketball
Association it's a young league we work
with young guys and try to give give
them opportunities exposure and
development this young kid had come up
to Atlanta to try out come from Miami to
try out and uh one of our professional
athletes that has taking rebound had a
game that Sunday and as you know FedEx
and uh ups and a lot of the services
that deliver don't really do it uh very
often on the weekend so we were having a
real difficult time because he had to
have it he knows the benefits of it we
show the comparison of rebound to
athletes and they know how significant
it is to get any little Edge because the
difference in winning and losing in
Superstar and a regular player and
making the NBA not is sometimes
fractions of a second so any Edge that
they can get athletes know they want it
so uh this kid was going back to Miami
and we we had the idea we met with the
kid and say look we've got an athlete
that needs this rebound desperately can
you on your trip back take a cap soon as
you get to the Miami Airport take a cap
go directly to the arena meet the
security guard in the back door and give
this uh rebound FX to this athlete and
he will give you two courtside seats for
it wow the kid was so elated and so
happy he said will I I'll be glad to so
the kid was uh we didn't have to tell
him about the benefits of rebound it was
obvious if this professional athlete
Superstar athlete wanted it this much it
had to be very good and he got a chance
to sit on the floor right near the
players's bench and see the game as he
never never seen it before and and see
rebound it work the athlete got his uh
his energy drink and he drank it
throughout the game and the benefits it
was just a win-win and a beautiful story
for everyone yeah that's that's I love
that story Mike thanks for sharing that
sure and of course you don't have to be
a basketball star a football star a
boxing star a baseball star to take
rebound effects if you're the sort of
person who needs to pick me up of a cup
of coffee or a soft drink at 10:00 in
the morning at 3:00 in the afternoon and
8:00 at night um you want to try rebound
FX it does not have carbonation it
doesn't have sugar it doesn't have
phosphates in it doesn't have the things
that are negatives from the standpoint
of
nutrition and as a result we find that
the people who were using rebound fxs
are people in addition to the athletes
of course it was originally designed for
athletes this is this is like gasoline
for a high performance race car and
you're not often going to get to use
that in street cars you know out in the
street because it's just such a high
performance fuel well here's a high
performance fuel for professional
athletes that's accessible and usable by
the average person on the street whether
you're kind of weekend warrior and
you're playing the company softball
league right yeah or you like to go
bowling on a Friday night or you just
like to um oh play tennis or Bas pickup
basketball um there there's so many
people who um break down regardless of
their age whether they're in their teens
on their young adults in their 20s or
30s yet middle-aged people and they
break down they say to me Doc I don't
know why I'm breaking down like this I'm
doing everything right I'm doing all my
fitness stuff and I'm drinking all the
water I'm keeping hydrated I'm
exercising or I'm drinking one of these
other sports drinks energy drinks and
you start show them the comparison and
they say well wait a minute this very
famous sports drink only has two
minerals in it
and rebound FX Has 77 plant minerals it
has a total of 128 nutrients in it wow
so how can you compare an energy drink
that has two nutrients versus one that
has 128 right is impossible and Doc
often times when I'm telling athletes
that I'll say imagine now that you're in
the boxing ring we're going a few years
back and I show them the compar and I
say uh you got this one minute break
between rounds and you're fighting the
young Mike Tyson which one do you want
so that brings it home clearly right
away give me a double dose of the
rebound they say so they athletes really
see the difference though the comparison
all the nutrition the energy the pickup
the ability to sustain your energy it's
just a no-brainer for anybody really you
know rebound f is really taken off Mike
and just because it is a performance
drink it is an energy drink and it is a
nutrient replacement not only a a fluid
replacer but it's also a nutrient
replacer and it's so convenient you
don't even have to pay for a lot of
water to be shipped to you it comes in a
concentrate you can get the samples a
one serving sample or you can get the
concentrate that has 32 servings in it
you can make it really concentrated as
32 half quarts or as it's designed for
32 quarts and you're only paying for the
shipping of one quart water instead of
32 so we're very excited about the
system it's uh really been very well
received by the professional athletes
from All Sports uh can you recall any
comments that maybe some of these
professional athletes have had about
rebound FX oh I have doc so many
athletes have really taken to it and
they've just ordered it in bulk I mean
we have entire teams that will purchase
as much as almost $2,000 worth at one
time and say I want to have this here
for the remainder of the year and I
don't want to have to worry about when
it's shipments coming in in and they
just take it every day they just will
not go on the court without it it
becomes that much more part of you you
just become you feel so much better when
you're walking on the floor with that
confidence as well as the energy your
body is just feeling good and they know
they can play at a very high level so
we've had athletes at every level
whether they're in the peeee level the
high school level the Collegiate level
or the professional ranks and and in all
sports whether they've been football
boxing basketball B baseball track you
name it we've had athletes across the
board that have just really loved taking
rebound effects well you're kind of an
all-around guy and one of the many many
reasons we have a deep respect for you
and we love you is that um uh you've
developed this league for de basketball
players yes and we really really
appreciate that and are these kids using
the rebound FX yes doc I'm glad you
asked about that this is a of course my
dad coached at Georgia school for the de
so I grew up around de kids he coached
basketball track and softball there in
the late 50s and early 60s so I grew up
around de kids and I developed the
nation's first basketball camp for de
kids so we get high school age boys and
girls basically from all across the
country to come to my camp we have a
weekl long of regular basketball camp
three times a day and on the last night
of the camp we play an allstar game
where my best DEA kids play against
local all stars from the community so
they're kind of it's been a long week
but they're very excited about
representing the Mike Glen Camp for the
hearing imp pair and about de people
showing that they can play basketball as
well as anybody else and uh so we played
and I remember the first time I
introduced uh rebound FX to them I just
told them very briefly this is a good
drink it has some nutrition it'll help
your energy so we're going to have it
available for the game so they said okay
and you know how high school kids are
they wonder how it taste and what is it
and they have been so accustomed to
other sports drinks and so I just put in
out and they were coming from and I I
told them huh drink some of this I had
someone to give it to them and I saw
their reactions when they go back on the
court they had the energy they came back
and I say which one you I want some more
of that one they were signed and they
wanted the one with the rebound in it
and they didn't even know of all the
nutritional things but all the whole
teams the girls and the boys were taking
it and after the game they were saying
how can I get some more of that so
without hearing the whole story and
knowing what it was going to do for them
that's like just a blind test it was for
a death test in this case but these kids
just tried it felt it they knew it
worked and they wanted it so and we've
had rebound available for them
throughout the week now for the last
couple of years but it is just a part of
the de Community the de Sports scene and
still growing uh in every Avenue you can
imagine well thank you for that feedback
Mike and and since you brought up the
test word yes um the thing that we're
really proud of with rebound FX and many
other of our products is the fact that
um in New Zealand which is probably the
toughest country in the world when it
comes to testing urine and testing sweat
of players to make sure that they're not
taking anything that gives them an
advantage something that's been banned
uh has been approved by the the agencies
in uh New Zealand that test for these
things and therefore it's also approved
because they're the toughest in the
world it's also um been approved by the
ioc wow the international Olympic
Committee and what does that do I mean I
know that a amateur and professional
athletes got to be worried when they're
going to take something new is it going
to affect um their their ability to play
are they going to get banned from
playing if they take something with some
weird Herb in it or something it shows
up their urine their sweat or their
blood um how how important is that to a
player that is Doc because it's so much
U emphasis on it now in the media every
all the emphasis on steroids or
different drugs that uh an athletes that
have died famous athletes and often they
try to infer that it was because of
something that they were taking or
rather than something that they're not
Tak there was a baseball player who died
of uh something and attributed to the
fedra that he was taken and then boy
Congress got in it and they they banned
the federal and then an attorney went
back and sued the government and the FDA
to get a fedra back on the market but it
has to be like a very very tiny tiny
dose you'd have to take a whole bottle
get the same doses you used to be able
to get oh okay right and I think that
doc has uh scared a few people like is
the federan so so they they have this uh
undo alarm so to know that it has been
stringently tested that these are
benificial nutrients and that's what we
really stress to people that this is
nutrition this is not some drug or
chemicals that you're putting in your
body this is the safest and the best
thing because they are plant derived
minerals have been predigested by plants
and so we explained that to them because
uh there is this concern that if it's
anything new that they've not heard of
that maybe it's one of those ban
substances that are will either make
them illegal to play or will hurt them
in the long run but once we tell them
these factors they they take it with
confidence and they know feel it and
like it and then uh they pretty pretty
much go on from there yeah this is a
rebound and several other products from
from uh our wonderful um collection of
products has been approved by at least
one and maybe two agencies in New
Zealand and again it's the toughest one
in the world and so the ioc the
international Olympic Committee just as
long as New Zealand says it's okay they
don't even look at it sideways and so um
this is really open opened up the whole
amateur Athletic League whether it's
Junior High High School uh University
Olympics and we're so very proud of that
because we don't want these young kids
who work so hard they learn the sport
the actual technology of the sport they
learn the system of the sports and then
they get fit and then they start
breaking down and it's always the top
ones yes it's always top it is Doc and I
think the top ones work harder you know
uh people in sports recognize that
sometimes people outside of sports think
they're just naturally gifted which they
are gifted or that they're just
naturally blessed and it comes easily to
them but from my experience as a
professional player from interviewing
writing books about them and seeing how
they work the guys that are stars are
usually the hardest working guys on your
team which means naturally they sweat
the most they lose their minerals the
most and we found these adverse health
effects on the best players because they
they sweat the most I mean they put more
energy more emotion more time they're
into the playoffs in the NBA if your
team does not make the playoffs your
season is over by the middle of April
but if you're going to the championship
game every year then you're going on to
toward the end of June so you have much
more intense games and practices and you
add that year to year to year those
superstars that are going that those
extra miles they're going to be the one
most adversely
affected well um thank you so much for
sharing all this information and I know
that people are going to want to hear
this this um material that is going to
be so vital to their long-term health
and also their their day-to-day Health
on the short term because nobody wants
to be walking around on crutches nobody
wants to be sitting in the chair when
you want to be out playing that's the
truth Doc and you know you made me think
of something else very quickly though uh
my wife who is a uh she likes to walk
and exercise try to stay firm and slim
uh around this area like in the Atlanta
area you have a lot of people that like
walking up Stone Mountain and walking
around the mountain so you have a lot of
people that are just doing those kind of
exercises daily and I know Phil's wife
likes to do these kind of things as well
and they both are taking this rebound FX
uh every day they're taking it to walk
the mountain for their exercise all
their friends are taking it so even if
you're not as we've mentioned a
professional athlete and you're
competing at that level if you're just
an everyday person that wants a little
extra energy and nutrition uh it works
very effectively it tastes great and um
it gives them that little extra energy
and they they'll do extra mile to when
they're taking that rebound and they
find out that uh they'll lose weight
quicker and actually and feel better
after they finish walking okay I'm going
to end this mic with rebound rebound
that's our dram I like that yes indeed P
be back in the Sports
World okay the you hear Mike Lynn and
both Mike and Dr W talking about you
know rebound and how we came about with
rebound and uh basically how our
relationship yourself and myself and
Mike um but I wanted you to kind of tell
your story and just kind of emphasize
why were you such a different athlete in
receiving this versus your colleagues
and what has it meant to
you well Phil um you know it's been
tremendous to me as far as uh helping
rebuild my career and further me along
and giving me the ability to extend my
career um you know it's been well
documented of the different type of
injuries that I've had throughout my
career and it always got to a point
where I couldn't figure out what was
going on with my body and um I overheard
Mike Glenn speaking to one of my
teammates when I was with the Atlanta
Hawks back in about 2002 talking about
minerals and calcium and mineral
deficiency and so when I heard him I
said yo Mike come over here and speak to
me about that a little bit and um he
graciously as he is as he is a man just
came over to and gave me some knowledge
about what it was he was speaking of and
it was uh profound and what he was what
he was speaking about because I had
never had it put to me in that manner as
far as athletes be becoming mineral and
calcium deficient you know throughout
their sweating out all their minerals
during play and also with the amount of
energy and stuff that we exert during
play you know I becom a deficient in
those areas so he told me about the
great products at uh youngevity and I
was able to get on the products
diligently you know and rebuild you know
the carage from my hip injury from my
knee injury and just all the different
things that I have going on at the time
you know I was in a situation where I
had the hip injury where I couldn't
figure out what was going on and know
why these things was just happening to
me you know because I always Tred to
keep myself in a superb physical health
and always ready to get out there and
play ball but you know I was getting
these minor injuries knickknack injuries
and stuff that was just stopping me from
continuing to be the player that I was
you know like I said with the minerals
that all changed once I got on the
minerals and got to doing the pig pack
plus and taking the calcium and being
diligent on it and taking it you know as
it was food you know every single day
twice a day I was able to rebuild my
body and to be able to extend my uh my
player career well Theo you know you uh
they had a WAP on you that you were the
kind of guy that got a lot of injuries
so why don't you just trying to tell me
when did your injury start and what you
know at what point did you realize that
there was something else that you needed
to do well I would di diagnosed even
when I first came into the league they
said I had a degenerative bone problem
how were you then that that was when I
just had come out of college I I wasn't
any more than
22 21 22 years old at the time so I had
back issues so as they looked at the uh
Mi I had to take Mi and a whole bunch of
exams in order for to teams to even take
me I had to take all these things to try
to make sure that you know everything
would stay intact and they gave me you
know only five or six years in the
league tops was where I would be at my
you know at my Peak position and
everything would be down here from there
because they saw the generative changes
that early in my career you know lo and
behold I was able to extend you know my
career as far as um being able to play
and be you know I was in a position
while I was in playoffs uh in as a
Allstar in 2001 right before um I
received my hip injury which no right
before I received my wrist injury where
I just went up for a block shot just
normally coming down trying to catch
myself you know fracturing my wrist
having to have surgery and then Trad it
to the Hawks and um then my wrist healed
and during that same summer right before
the season started I end up tearing
College I didn't know what it was I just
went up for the ball jumped for a ball a
routine thing that I do you know a
thousand times a game and end up tearing
Carlos in my hip nobody knew what the
diagnose was you know I had to go see
all these Specialists and different
things that would you and finally figure
out what was going on so I had to have a
surgery for that and in my trying to
recovery from that surgery
I just um wasn't getting back to being
able to play the game and it had gotten
to a point where I had set out all year
tried to come back a couple of times and
it just wouldn't happen for me
so I had you know lost faith in you know
what was going on as far as with trying
to heal and was real discouraged with
what the doctors and stuff were saying
and you know I thought I was pretty much
done with because I wouldn't be able to
be the same player that I was before I
had the hip injury but with with that
said uh had a great gu Phil Oliver to
school me on exactly what I needed to do
as far as taking the minerals and the
calcium along with Mike Glenn and you
know just got over my problem by being
diligent on taking the product and so
from there we produce rebound yes so how
is rebound now that we have this rebound
effects how has it benefited you and
even some of your
colleagues well after being such a
diligent uh student of the minerals and
the calcium and constantly uh rebuilding
my body um we kind of jointly me pH Mike
kind of jointly came up with the idea of
having an energy drink to help
sustain me throughout the game when
everybody else was going down in the
fourth quarter my energy was still
elevating and staying at its peak
position and you know with that
said being three-time you know shot
block leader you know one of the top
defenders in the league been um pretty
much winner up to being defensive
Defensive Player of the Year and
different things of that nature um it
definitely help Excel my career
and by me having such a success me
seeing the success that I had I wanted
to wanted to go out to my colleagues and
try to introduce them to these products
as far as with the minerals and have
them to understand what what's going on
with their bodies when they're going out
they're sweating sweating out your
minerals using your calcium during play
and being able to replenish themselves
with something that was healthy at the
same time efficient so prior of that
nobody explained to you about sweat how
important what your sweating out is
replacing it back in prior to meeting Dr
Wall Mike Glenn and of course myself no
one because you were around nutritionist
you around doctors no one ever um
explained it to you in that manner no no
no one ever really broke it down to me
on what minerals are how they work you
know we get the basic four food groups
and you need to be eating more
carbohydrates and different things of
that nature but never to the detail on
what helps build your body and what
helps you sustain your body as far as
how you losing sweat how how you losing
your minerals through sweat and
different things of that Nation no one
ever sat down you until I met you feel
you uh Phil Mike and Dr wck and they
really uh educated me on that and so now
we have a crusade we're trying to just
expose this information to not only just
athletes but to everybody who needs
energy everybody need these minerals how
often do you need them oh you need
minerals like I said just like you have
food you know every single day you need
to replenish yourself with the right
minerals and you know to help have
longevity you know in life you know to
to live with you know being deceased
free you know different things of that
nature and being able to to have a
healthy lifestyle that's that's what
it's all about that's how Crusade is to
try to give everybody Ultimate Health
well I tell you that's a great Crusade
and uh we thank God for you for Rebound
fxs and I think we'll sign off with
saying let's go rebound let's go rebound
all right all right
[Music]